you're here tonight for the Nicholas
Oakwell Couture autumn winter 2013
collection what are you looking forward
to I'm so excited to see the show I've
been so impressed with Nicholas
literally placed his last few seasons
that I'm just really excited about what
he's got in store I'm wearing I'm
wearing a very comfortable suit from his
last collection right now which I adore
and he always comes he always finds
something interesting a new angle
inspired internationally historically he
always finds a twist I mean what he does
so I'm looking forward to what his
imagination has come up with this time
talking about twists and imaginations
you've had lots of twists and turns on
season three of Game of Thrones haven't
we so far what was your reaction to the
red wedding it was such a joy to watch
the reaction of the on the red wedding I
was actually in Madrid at a screening so
I was with about 800 sort of shocked and
awed Spaniards when I saw that episode
and I thought it was it was done
brilliantly I thought it was handled
really well and you know it really kind
of took your breath away I was really
impressed with what they had managed to
achieve
we've had some veils we'll Burleigh
veiled threats from Cersei Lena Headey
character haven't we - Margaery last
season what do you make of that we start
shooting in a couple of weeks time so
I'm going back to Belfast to start
shooting and I do believe that Nina and
myself have got some scenes to get our
teeth into so and great female
characters of the show you were one of
them of course Lena another a lander is
world trying to rig was new last season
as well what was it like working with
her of course is your grandmother what I
loved about Game of Thrones is
that they write incredibly strong women
not scared of strong women and Nicolas
Oakwell the way he designs designs for
strong women
you